es una carrera contrarreloj para salvar
la mayor cantidad de vida silvestre
posible más de 572.000 litros de
petróleo crudo se derramaron en la costa
del sur de california
el derrame cubrió 33 kilómetros
cuadrados que van desde huntington beach
hasta la playa de newport es una zona
que normalmente está llena de bañistas y
surfistas ahora sus costas están
cubiertas de peces muertos y petróleo
estamos en medio de un potencial
desastre ecológico aquí en huntington
beach
urgimos a las partes responsables a
hacer todo lo posible para rectificar
esta catástrofe ambiental
el vertido de petróleo fue causado por
un fallo en un oleoducto conectado una
plataforma gestionada por beta option la
que es propietaria amplifier energy
corporation el director general de la
firma asegura que el oleoducto ya ha
sido cerrado y que la empresa está
trabajando para identificar el origen de
la fuga
actualmente tenemos buzos en el lugar el
sitio de la fuente potencial estamos
investigando el origen y la posible
causa de este incidente descenso lente
se trata de uno de los mayores derrames
de petróleo en la historia reciente del
sur de california ya en 2015 se
filtraron más de 378 mil litros de crudo
en la costa de santa barbara
los activistas ambientales dicen que
este último derrame subraya una vez más
la necesidad de que el estado pase de
los combustibles fósiles a las energías
renovables